genau hier war es hier vom reichstag
haben sie demonstriert zehntausende
manchmal hunderttausende kinder und
jugendliche alles voll und haben druck
ausgeübt plötzlich war das thema wichtig
wie andere berichtet auch ich reite ist
future erinnert sich jemand und jetzt
ist ding ist leer
corona abstandsgebot hygieneregeln
versammlungsverbot und das thema
klimaschutz können wir uns das noch
leisten oder kann das weg
hallo ich bin florian hahn aus dem
zdf-hauptstadtstudio in berlin und ich
frage mich ist das euer ernst machen wir
wirklich eine pause mit dem klimaschutz
gerade um geld da ist diese sache mit
dem lebenswerten planeten kurz egal
das gucken wir uns jetzt mal an hier
kommen die drei für mich wichtigsten
punkte zum klimaschutz in der korona
krise und was die politik dazu sagt und
am ende die entscheidende frage
billionen werden ausgegeben nur wofür
eigentlich was wir hier in berlin in
diesen tagen erleben ist eine lobby
schlag wie ich sie noch nie erlebt haben
es geht um millionen um geld das jetzt
hier konjunkturprogramme bereitgestellt
werden soll und alle wollen einen teil
davon abgekommen ja zum beispiel die
autoindustrie die haben eine idee eine
kaufprämie für autos nicht nur für
elektroautos sondern für alle also
benziner diese dreckschleudern ja das
kennen wir doch schon damals 2009 nach
der finanzkrise diese art fragt prämie
zweieinhalbtausend euro gab es für jedes
auto das man von schrotten liest das war
dann ein kurzes strohfeuer für die
gesamtwirtschaft bisschen geld für die
industrie und klima mäßig habt ihr was
gemerkt viel blech auf der straße mehr
co2 mehr feinstaub und die klimabilanz
ziemlich mäßig ungefähr alle ökonomen
gerade sagen sowas zu wiederholen wäre
ziemlicher unsinn ziemlicher unsinn
ziemlicher unsinn
trotzdem gibt es in der politik mächtige
fürsprecher den wirtschaftsminister
peter altmaier und dann noch drei
ministerpräsidenten aus ländern wo
zufälligerweise die autoindustrie sitzt
niedersachsen bayern und kaum zu glauben
auch der grüne winfried kretschmann aus
baden württemberg ist dafür
sowas zu wiederholen wäre ziemlicher
unsinn ziemlich herunter ziemlich herr
unsinn woran das wohl liegen kann keine
lobby ist so einflussreich wie die
automobil
liegt vielleicht auch an den personen
die der handel hildegard müller früher
staatsministerin im kanzleramt bei
kurzem präsidentin der autolobby oder
eckart von klaeden früher ebenfalls ganz
nah am jetzt chef lobbyist von daimler
und schließlich thomas steg früher mal
regierungssprecher bei merkel jetzt
cheflobbyist bei vw nur noch mal fürs
protokoll
die experten die was zu sagen haben sind
dagegen die umweltministerin auch viel
geld wenig ertrag und box fürs klima
wollt ihr uns das ernsthaft noch mal
verkaufen
sowas zu wiederholen wäre ziemlicher
unsinn ziemlicher unsinn ziemlicher
unsinn
2 was die da trainieren wollen es nicht
irgendwas sondern der green deal der
eu-kommission ein megaprojekt dies ist
man nun moment die mondlandung 2050 soll
die eu danach klimaneutral wird keine
co2 emissionen ausstoßen und bis 2030
ehrgeizige ziele erreichen - 55 prozent
emissionen im vergleich zu 190 tonnen
vor der krise war das manchen viel zu
ehrgeizig jetzt kommen diese kritiker
wieder um die ecke neuer vorwand eben
corona da ist zum beispiel der hier der
tschechische ministerpräsident badisch
und auch in berlin hören wir jetzt
wieder stimmen etwa aus dem
wirtschaftsflügel der union die sagen
das muss alles auf den prüfstand
das klingt so nett aber ich übersetze
mal das heißt kann weg kann weg kann weg
aber setzen sie sich damit auch durch
wer entscheidet das da war ja noch
jemand fast vergessen
ich kann sagen klimaschutz ist für uns
ein wichtiger teil unserer arbeit
richtig die klimakanzlerin
so hat man merkel mal genannt wegen
solcher fotos
es ist irgendwie nie was draus geworden
war immer etwas wichtigeres zu tun aber
jetzt kam das hier europa soll bis 2050
der erste klimaneutrale kontinent werden
wow das war erstaunlich deutlich gerade
für merkels verhältnisse erstmals hatte
sich eindeutig festgelegt für den green
deal und für das ziel - 50 bis 55
prozent emissionen bis 2030 nur noch mal
kurz 2030 das sind noch zehn jahre
bis dahin soll die hälfte der co2
emissionen weg die frage ist doch jetzt
wie handelt sie in frankreich hat
präsident ma con gerade beschlossen air
force zu retten
unter einer bedingung gibt es einen
schnellzug der das ziel in weniger als
zweieinhalb stunden erreicht ist der
kurzstreckenflug gestrich keine
kurzstreckenflüge mehr in frankreich und
in deutschland
in deutschland wird die lufthansa
gerettet mit milliarden vom steuerzahler
richtig so nur so eine klima bedingung
spielt keine rolle
da wird nicht mal diskutiert das ist
jetzt nur ein beispiel
aber eines das klarmacht von klimaschutz
zu reden und danach zu handeln sind zwei
verschiedene paar schuhe also
zusammengefasst wir erleben gerade eine
autoindustrie die relativ dreist
kaufprämien von uns allen fordert ihr
leben wie der green deal also das mega
projekt der europäischen kommission
heftig angeschossen wird und wir erleben
eine klimakanzlerin die vielleicht
zurückkommt aber jetzt mal konkret
werden müsste
ich kann sagen klimaschutz ist für uns
ein wichtiger teil unserer abend hier
sitzt die klimakanzlerin und das sind
die drei wichtigsten punkte die sie
jetzt entscheiden sollte erstens finger
weg von dieser kauf oder abwrackprämie
für autos zweitens dranbleiben am green
deal für europa und drittens jeder euro
muss auf dem klimaschutz prüfstand nur
so kann es funktionieren klimaschutz und
corinna gemeinsam also wenn wir schon
den jugendlichen wegen corona große
schuldenberge hinterlassen dann noch
wenigstens auch eine lebenswerte zukunft
auf diesem planeten
oder was meint ihr schreibt es mir in
die kommentare
und wenn es euch gefallen hat abonniert
doch diesen kanal